[Música]
el aburrimiento tiene muy mala fama en
general se le ha definido con conceptos
muy negativos como tedio hastío tristeza
perezosa le han llamado algunos hay
muchos conceptos que se le asocian
se ha vinculado con trastornos clínicos
como la depresión como la
procrastinación y hasta el abuso de
sustancias además de otras conductas de
alto riesgo
el aburrimiento es muy importante en
nuestras vidas realmente dejamos de
hacer cosas o hacemos cosas por
aburrimiento sin embargo no todos nos
aburrimos igual ni en las mismas
circunstancias hay aburrimiento más
crónico por ejemplo hay personas que
tienen un aburrimiento crónico muy
pesado y hay personas que en general se
aburren de forma temporal y pasajera
pero que nos aburre hay autores que han
dicho que el aburrimiento es con un
privilegio de clase porque para estar
aburrido se necesita estar saciado
satisfecho que no haya una emergencia ni
haya una necesidad solo así me puedo
aburrir
me aburre también estar esperando por
mucho tiempo en periodos en condiciones
de estimulación muy parecida nos aburre
también cuando estamos ante una
actividad demasiado fácil para nosotros
que no implica un esfuerzo mental pero
también nos puede aburrir algo que es
demasiado complicado por ejemplo si
estamos leyendo un libro que nos parece
muy pesado que no le vemos algo personal
no nos da sentido y es muy probable que
nos aburra
y nuestra cultura satanista el
aburrimiento realmente nos enseña desde
niños desde niñas que hay que llenar el
tiempo de muchas actividades de
divertirnos de hacer cosas nuevas todo
el tiempo
nos evita pensar básicamente no le gusta
que nos quedemos quietos y divagando
porque dice aquí hay problemas los niños
aburridos dan problemas los jóvenes
aburridos dan problemas vemos niñitos
por ejemplo hasta con aparatos
electrónicos y a veces no saben ni
caminar
pero lo que queremos es que no se
aburran vemos jóvenes en la escuela por
ejemplo que
valoran de sobremanera a los profesores
muy divertidos con muchas dinámicas no
importa el contenido de su materia no
importa la profundidad con que lo toquen
lo que se valora es que tan entretenido
es el profesor los adultos también lo
hacemos
nuestras formas de diversión
generalmente implican una
sobreestimulación
un lugar para bailar por ejemplo o algún
bar está lleno de luces de sonidos muy
fuertes que ni siquiera nos permiten
conversar
lo que queremos es estimulación
a pesar de esta de esta mala fama que
tiene el aburrimiento de este miedo que
se le tiene y que la cultura nos inculca
porque una persona aburrida consume más
a pesar de ello el aburrimiento es
positivo el aburrimiento tiene muchas
bondades porque
cuando nosotros estamos concentrados en
algo muy particular con un esfuerzo
mental particular se activa una red en
el cerebro llamada fronto parietal
es responsable precisamente de mantener
el foco atencional y el esfuerzo s esos
procesos voluntarios cuando yo descanso
cuando me canso cuando me aburro esa red
se desactiva pero se activa a otra no
quiere decir que el cerebro se queda sin
hacer nada no se activa una red que más
bien promueve procesos muy complejos
como cuáles como los procesos reflexivos
introspectivos resolución de problemas
en la memoria autobiográfica por ejemplo
a quien no le ha pasado que está
descansando está divagando su mente y de
repente se le ocurre una idea fantástica
o se le ocurre la resolución de un
problema que tenía y cristian h hace que
voy a hacer
el aburrimiento permite eso
hay muchos estudios que hablan de que
cuando dejamos a la gente aburrirse
cuando no la llenamos de estímulos la
gente solita empieza a innovar solita
empieza a llenar los vacíos sin
necesitar estimulación porque esta
cultura que nos llena de estímulos nos
hace dependientes de esos estímulos y
todo el tiempo queremos que nos
diviertan en cambio si aprendemos a
educar el aburrimiento
precisamente podemos volvernos
autogestivos por lo tanto yo los invito
a que nos aburramos y yo les recomiendo
cuatro elementos hay muchos otros pero
cuatro para empezar primer elemento
tolera el aburrimiento
aguanta cuando estás en una condición
aburrida tolera espera concentrate un
poco si puedes en tu cuerpo que sientes
que puedes voltear al lugar donde te
encuentras concentrate si no puedes más
descansa párate muévete observa el cielo
los edificios las flores no se a otras
personas
tercer elemento regresa a la actividad
aburrida por qué
una de las cosas que más nos aburren es
cuando no encontramos sentido a las
actividades imagínense que va en alguna
vez a la ópera por primera vez es muy
probable que les parezca aburrido y
pesado muy probable pero si vuelven a
escuchar esa ópera una y otra y otra vez
que creen les va a gustar piensen que
hay muchas actividades que antes les
aburría y ahora les gustaban por eso es
importante regresar a esa actividad
aburrida y en cuarto lugar ten espacio
en su vida al ocio a esa actividad por
la que no le pagan no les pagan no
tienen algo en particular
material ni prestigio pero tienen un
disfrute muy particular que además les
permiten en una actividad preciosa o en
una afición permiten que precisamente
esa red atencional
que es contraria a la a la atención
focal esa red neural por defecto se
active y ustedes mientras hacen su
afición las cosas que les gustan
precisamente dan oportunidad al cerebro
a generar esos procesos tan importantes
para la vida humana como la creatividad
como la autobiografía como la planeación
etcétera por lo tanto repito los invito
a aburrirse no teman al aburrimiento